[Music]
when we talk about things like free will
or whether you know the basics of
mathematical truths or realism you know
whether there's a world out there at all
whether they're moral truths that these
are questions for which we don't yet
have and maybe never will by their very
nature have any empirical evidence one
way or the other or it can make we
really you know knock down arguments
that are going to convince your
opponents I mean we have we been great
passion to these these discussions and
to these attitudes about these questions
my feeling is it's these are intuitions
and what's so interesting about them is
that they're individually variable they
they vary from one individual to the
next David you had said that you know
when we're philosophical arguments in
evidence end psychology comes into play
you know and that so for example
causality you know we can't justify our
belief and comes out at a you know that
there always is a cause for events and
that it will continue in the future and
yet you know even that doesn't stop any
of us from believing it and we can
survive if we didn't believe in it and
so he I see Hume is a sort of
predecessor and making the kind of
argument that I'm making about
philosophy you know that we're reason
ends and argument ends and even
empirical evidence ends human psychology
steps in he says somewhere in the
treatise on human nature that nature is
too strong for us and so what steps in
the kinds of intuitions that I'm
interested and he was talking about
intuitions that are shared by all of us
just in virtue of being human and
being reasonable characters but kind of
intuitions that I think are really
interesting and then haven't been paid
much attention to our vary from one
person to the next
and I think if you look at the history
of philosophy you can actually go
through the great thinkers and say what
was that core intuition and the core
intuition I mean the last thing you
would give up in the face of
recalcitrance experience you know what
was the last thing so Spinoza was a
great favorite of mine his core
intuition and everything kind of makes
sense once you see this is that reality
is intelligible there are always reasons
for every fact nothing is just a root
fact it's true because it's true and
nothing else no you know the way I like
to put in it so now Turtles going all
the way down its reasons going all the
way down and that is firstly so that's
like a core intuition of his for Hume
it's quite the opposite it's like no
it's contingency you know reason stops
and it's not just that our reason stops
the reasons stop there are just brute
facts for context-free well he'll do
anything he'll change around any part of
his system as long as he preserves
pretty well because we have to have free
well for that's to have moral
responsibility and so it's just a sort
of fascinating um
fact I think about philosophers it's not
so much a full stuff go full circle
point it's sort of the psychology of
philosophy and I guess what I would want
to argue is a lot of psychology is in
play in the history of philosophy
I mean philosophical discussions now and
when radically disagree with each other
about all sorts of philosophical
questions that there is temperament
there's personality there is one's
entire orientation towards you know
reality or whether or not you want to
say reality within scare
quotes or reality without scare quotes
my intuition tells me to say so I
actually I mean I'm my own intuition
still with me
oh yes no there is objective truth it
really is truth out there I'm a very
strong realist certainly when it comes
to science but actually mathematics I'm
a very strong you know that's when it
comes to mathematics I'm rather a strong
realist when it comes to morality and
even aesthetics so my intuition is it
realize I'm and spread that probably is
my core orientation I mean and I think
there's an objective truth there I mean
in that sense I think realism has to ask
for you know it's kind of answers itself
it's sort of because if somebody you
know just agrees with me about real as a
little they say well that's what's
really real you know that's Fitz it's
it's it's hard to not somehow come down
on the side of objective truth and and
realism but it's an entirely different
proposition to say that we can know
reality and that we are ever certain of
the truth I think quite often people
merge the question of whether there's
truth and whether realism is true with
the epistemological questionable whether
we can know the truth and whether we can
you know everybody certain know that and
you know in there that's totally
different question
and I would say yeah no I mean the truth
if we know anything about it or anything
is there anything that we want to know
about it says very hard to come by to
meet it's pretty amazing
given our evolutionary roots right that
we are evolved chimps basically then we
know anything at all you know and that
we have developed these self-critical
methodologies both philosophy and and
science and the social sciences as well
to interrogate
our selves and so that we we do a
approach closer and closer to you know
something in the truth you know I do I
do think that there's a tremendous
amount that we don't know and possibly
can never know
so that affect my realism commits me to
that right I think you know because I
think there really is a reality it's you
know some some get a little glimmers of
it if we're very very strict with
ourselves and we're really interrogate
our own beliefs and we pool our shared
knowledge and pool our resources that
you know we can know something I think
it's probably very little but but enough
for us to believe in truth so yeah by
talking about intuitions what I'm doing
is talking about the limits on our own
knowledge making it more of a claim
about knowledge rather than truth we
really do know that there are laws of
nature and that we don't know all of
them
and we don't know why they are the laws
of nature but we do know something about
the laws of nature through science and
always we know it's not the last word we
correcting ourselves there was Newton
okay mine Steinem tivity theory -
correct
Newton just show that it was only a
limiting case and when if we take
velocities that are very large that you
know Newtonian mechanics breaks and also
wilberth dealing with things that are
moving very very fast I just said that
yes we're taking philosophies that are
very large or quantum mechanics that
we're dealing with a very very small
Newtonian physics breaks down so you
know each at each stage all we can say
is we have an approximation of the laws
of nature we keep pushing it pushing it
in we find out it's just an
approximation we're back to the drawing
board
but I do you think we know that there
are laws of nature it's an orange
self-interest to discover the laws of
nature I think for example we know on
the basis of pretty solid science not
terribly sophisticated that the climate
that the climate is is warming we
understand why it's more I mean we
understand what carbon emissions are
doing it was interestingly predicted on
the basis of shear theory in 1896 by
Swedish physicist Arenas who said you
know this could happen in like another
four hundred years right you know that
burning coal and such things are going
to trap moisture going to create a
sealing trap moisture and it's all going
to warm up you know happen a little
faster than he thought but I think we
know this and we know why it happened it
was predicted I think we know that there
are laws of nature that they govern
physical reality and that we know some
of these physical laws well enough to
make predictions and and to try to
counteract what is bad for the survival
of our planet and all the creatures on
and I think we really know this I don't
think it's I think that some of the
controversies that took place and very
much in the 1960s 1970s around Thomas
Kuhns book the structure of scientific
revolutions big book most a signed book
still in American universities you know
that there's no science doesn't make
progress that it's always you know there
are these paradigm shifts that are akin
to a religious conversion and you just
change your frame you change the game
blah blah blah I think I think this was
wrong it was very very fashionable and
and it was it seeped out into the
intellectual
this fear in such a way that people you
know doubted the expertise of science in
any way I think that was wrong
here's another sphere altogether you
know I think we know that slavery is
wrong took us a really long time to
figure that out
great great thinkers like Plato and
Aristotle these great moral thinkers we
tend to easier you know Alfred North
Whitehead said all of whole history of
Western philosophy consists of footnotes
to Plato well he started in methodology
but he didn't know he never thought to
question the institution of slavery I
think we know that it's wrong it's
absolutely wrong for people to take
possession of other people nobody has
the right to do that I think we know a
lot of things about rights and so here
I'm two quite different examples one
scientific one moral and I think that we
know these things there's a real
breakdown for me that's the most
fundamental breakdown for me to say that
there's absolute truth sometimes some
things are absolutely true some things I
think it's absolutely true for example
the slavery is wrong I think that's
absolutely true
no exceptions but you know so it's but
it's not to equate these two concepts of
objective truth and absolutely too thin
nor is it to ever
you know equate the notion that there's
truth with a claim that we know it you
know we're in a absolute privileged
position to do to claim it at this
moment that we know know it these are
all three separate kinds of claims it's
perhaps relevant then a grew up in a
very religious household and
fundamentalist kind of household and I
was constantly being told this is the
way the world is you know there's this
God and he wants you to do this thing
once you do that and you know and he did
this that and the other and
I always would my first instinct was
always to say how do you really how do
you know that that's true and it was it
seems to me so very basic when people
were telling me all of these things and
saying this is how you have to live your
life because we know this to be true how
do you know it but I was quite sure that
it was either true or wasn't and that I
needed to try you know that that
intuition yes it's for these
propositions they're either true or
they're not it's not that it's true for
my family but not true for my family the
family next door who believe differently
they believe that I I had to accept
Jesus Christ as my my Savior is going to
go to hell that was quite different
belief than put my parents who were
Jewish believed one of them was wrong
they couldn't both be right that seemed
to me yeah from the earliest age so
that's my deepest intuition that that
you know when people assert certain
things they're either right or wrong I
know my husband for example it doesn't
like chocolate he thinks it tastes
terrible I think it's the most of my
taste in the world it's right or I'll
know about that you know you know about
taste there is no dispute right there is
there's no objective fact of the matter
but in certain realms yes I mean I'm
either going to go to hell or not
because I have enough accepted Jesus as
my savior
I either I won't you know and it's
there's an objective truth there so
where does it come from that comes from
my earliest childhood being told all
sorts of things were true wondering you
know how people could know that these
things were true and being sure that
they were either true or false
not to me that just seems like logic for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you